one of the awesome things about Maker
Faires finding people who figured out
how to take their everyday hobbies and
turn them into life's eyes awesomeness
like this and like this Shawn Thornton
based in Petaluma California out of his
abandoned chicken barn has put together
a workshop where he's building an army
of armor and weapons all based off of
halo I asked him what it takes to start
putting this stuff together this is what
he said well I start with the program
called pepakura takes a 3d model unfolds
it lays it flat so you can build it in
paper you know cardstock after that I go
ahead and I refine it using bondo and
fiberglass to reinforce it smooth it out
shape it make it a little bit more of a
finished piece once I've got that done I
make a silicone rubber mold with
fiberglass jacket to our mother mold to
keep it all right shape out of the mold
I go ahead and make rotocast copies and
urethane resin and then once that's done
I've got a hollow shell that's the same
shape as the original which needs a
little bit of sanding and shaping and
smoothing before I can go through the
trouble of priming it painting it and
doing all the weathering and detail nice
part about this is they all get to be a
little different so I don't have to be
exactly perfect castings Sean and his
associates have been working on their
armor for over ten years now but about
two years back they decided to make this
their full-time gig they've already done
a halo fan film let's see what they got
coming up in the future
you